somebody said told me today marks the
day that it's like the sweet 16 of the
Destiny's Child survivor album Wow which
is very cool Wow yeah you what's the
most fondest memory of that period you
know what's funny I don't remember I
really I know I'm not such a whirlwind
it was such a whirlwind actually the
most fondest memory of that time was
meeting Michael Jackson I remember
performing at his 20th anniversary
special and us going to Tavern on the
Green and meeting him like waiting for
him just like so excited to meet him and
he came over singing bootylicious really
yes because it was like of course he
inspired that record and of course like
Stevie Nicks but it was just like the
fact that he was singing my songs which
is like oh my gosh that is crazy
oh my gosh so that moment incredible
mm-hmm so what we're expecting in the
project um authenticity yeah I'll keep
it there but authenticity always wonder
when musicians say authenticity if they
do the question what is authentic no not
what is authentic what does that mean
the password could you turn field off as
authentic it's not that I think that
it's more so like it's very relevant for
where I am right now and me being
completely authentic and for me you've
always been authentic but you just
continue to grow and know and learn
yourself better and you think you know
what I want to talk about more than
motivation in kisses down low you know
what I mean is just like another layer
to you and I think that it's nothing
it's nothing wrong with that and you
want to be able to share that with all
of your fans and listeners and even
create new and find new listeners so
that's what's exciting to me about this
project do you feel pressure to it
there's a obviously you you know you
you've done the dance thing and you've
done RB thing and you've done different
rounds in this there's a sound right now
you feel pressure to kind of it kind of
adopt some of those sounds and some that
by the wave that's going on right now
I love the sound right now yeah I saw
love it
but I'm absolutely in love with like on
I love six black I love Colleen I love
her it's a great artist I love the Drake
just put out this amazing record and and
passionate food is one of my favorite
songs on that album but it's just it
feels good you know what I mean I think
that music for me is just starting to
feel good again like the weekend did
that so effortlessly on his last record
and I'm just like oh my god so largest
record was amazing these record was
amazing I thought because they're my
sisters but because they just they did
it it was just awesome and it it pushed
thought and made people I think that
when you listen to some of those lyrics
you were either inspired or you felt
responsible afterwards and I feel like
music is supposed to do that that's what
Marvin Gaye did for us what Stevie
Wonder difference like it's you know
what I mean I feel the responsibility to
make sure that the music is not just
cute outfits that you know what I mean